another well-known chain store is going
out of business this big story Dress
Barn is closing all 650 of its locations
whoa whoa wait hold on what did you say
oh I was just talking about Dress Barn
Barn show some goddamn respect for the
bar I am so sorry I lost control but I
mean I must have misheard you
because I thought you said Dress Barn
was going out of business no that's that
is exactly what I said no no no no no no
hold on I have a direct line to Dress
Barn I'll get to the bottom of this oh
my god the lines dead oh my god I'm
already too late well if this isn't just
like Dress Barn okay Andy Andy are you
okay I had had no idea you cared this
much about Dress Barn well maybe if you
asked once in a while it's always Andy
how's your health
Andy how are your kids dress and barn
okay I'm I'm really sorry Andy I should
have spent more time asking you clearly
about Dress Barn man when I knew it when
Dress Barn CEO David Jaffe retired
things were gonna go straight down the
[ __ ]
I said his report or his replacement
Gary mudo was not up for the challenge
but did they listen to old Andy Richter
no now I feel like a real idiot for
getting this
that tattoo looks really fresh when did
you get that a couple nights ago but
it's only because this one was starting
to fade you know I have to say this is
all coming as kind of a surprise I mean
business has closed all the time and
there are lots of other options I mean
there's an Taylor Loft there's Eileen
Fisher wipe my ass with an Eileen Fisher
what you want sensible well-crafted
dresses and skirts at an affordable
price point in a location within
spitting distance of a jo-ann's fabric
store its dress part or nothing conan
woods just put it up what does this look
like to you it just looks like a map of
Dress Barn locations in fact that's what
it says right at the top of those maybe
you see Dress Barn locations but me I
see a map of Memories I only remember my
mother's birthday because it's the same
day as the annual Dress Barn Anza
half-price dress dressing sash sale and
the Dress Barn in the Deer Grove
shopping center the one next to the
store that sells catheters that's where
I lost my virginity I mean with without
dress bar and I have no memories I'm I'm
not even sure who I am anymore you know
now that you mention it I I do remember
you telling me about losing your
virginity and a dress barn
well I'm sorry Andy that's not your
fault Conan
[Laughter]
you know whose fault it is your stress
barn and your parent company I've seen a
retail group Dress Barn to meet you were
more than a barn for dresses you were a
temple and now you've desecrated that
temple this is how much I hate you now
Dress Barn we only have one of those
chairs hey can we bring any a less
expensive chair to smash please Thank
You Bobby yeah that's great thanks how
much I hate you Dress Barn
[Applause]
I'm coming for you Dress Barn
- all 650 locations and I'm bringing
hell with me
okay well we've got a great show you're
young I will burn you to the ground from
friends the comeback and the new movie
look smart Emmy award-winning actress
Lisa Kudrow's on the show